hey youtubers it's Charlie I know
everybody's freaking out about the flash
so this is gonna be my episode 22 video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet no surprise here my number one
WTF was definitely the killing of Henry
Allen at the end but like I said the
last couple of videos I feel like what
they're doing is is they kill off Henry
Allen on earth one but then the man in
the iron mask turns out to be the real
Jay Garrick played by John Wesley Shipp
she is this amazing WTF twist that
pushes Barry over the edge the stakes
have never been higher but you also get
this amazing payoff at the end and they
did say that in the finale they will
take the iron mask off so whatever ends
up happening we will find out for sure
but I just feel like that's the
direction they're headed so let's do top
10 WTF Easter eggs all kinds of awesome
stuff in this episode especially a lot
of Easter eggs for the classic 90s flash
series so number 10 WTF we are having
the blackest of nights in Central City
iris West nice blackest night shout out
I don't think they'd ever be able to do
that on the TV show without doing Green
Lantern's but it's always awesome when
they name drop giant comic book arcs so
number 9 welcome back Tina McGee they
don't really say what the amazing thing
she's working on is I'm wondering if the
big breakthrough is gonna have something
to do with the finale but one of many
badass saves from Barry midair as the
building is collapsing you can
definitely tell they save money for all
the visual effects in this episode but
no surprise she totally knows that
Barry's the flash I'm a scientist you
know I'm not dumb leading to number 8
WTF meeting John Wesley Shipp so we get
a classic 90s flash moment oh hello my
name is Henry Allen hello I'm Tina McGee
so nice to meet you they even had a bit
of a moment at the end of the
episode before everything went sideways
if you didn't watch the original flash
90 series Tina McGee was Barry Allen's
love interest John Wesley Shipp played
Barry Allen in that series so even
though it only ran for a little while
they were kind of like the Barry and
iris of that TV series so the sexual
chemistry right here that's just a wink
at that but number seven WTF Wally wants
to pay the flashback to prove that he is
worthy of being saved he also has all
this that he's carrying on his
shoulders he feels bad about not
visiting his mother more before she died
he feels bad about Barry losing his
powers he feels responsible for that so
this is just part of the path that Wally
is on to becoming a here
on the show I totally think that he'll
be a hero of some kind no idea what's
gonna happen with powers but number six
WTF I should say
Jessie quick is testing herself again to
see if she's become a metahuman but
there's a speech from Harrison wells
where he's like you're not special
because you have powers you're special
because you're a genius
that can help us so please help us right
now what I think they're doing with
Wally and Jessie is they just want you
to wonder if they're gonna ever get
powers so they're just gonna play with
your expectations
and hopefully there'll be some more
winking at that in the finale but I
think they take most of season 3 to
explore whatever that might end up
turning into the number five WTF though
is Caitlin's PTSD and how's this going
to affect her going into next season she
just keeps hallucinating zoom this
actually ties back around with zooms
storyline zoom is unable to get over the
trauma of watching his mother die how it
led to him becoming a serial killer
this evil metahuman speedster so because
Caitlin is one of the protagonists I
think she's on more of a hopeful arc she
will slowly learn to get past it with
the help of her friends it's not gonna
go away overnight like she's not just
gonna be fine next week which is some of
my complaints about arrow with Thea's
bloodlust like I'll just say that Thea
is acting with her bloodlust this season
has been somewhat inconsistent as to
when she's feeling bloodlust when she's
not feeling it danielle panabaker to her
credit is just a slightly more
experienced actor so I think she's gonna
be a little more consistent through yet
PTSD Caitlin then you have Caitlin who's
doing a little bit better but she's not
bipolar so she's not gonna be bouncing
back and forth between super happy
funtime Caitlin and super depressed dark
Caitlin number four meet black siren
that was an amazing introduction doesn't
everybody wish Laurel on arrow was like
that does it not make you upset that we
could have had that version of Laurel
this whole time had they not spun their
wheels so much on people having powers
on that TV show we're not doing powers
on arrow cut to season 2 Barry Allen
boom
well I guess we're doing powers on this
show oh well whatever she's still alive
she's in prison so she could totally
come back in a future season pending
whatever ends up happening in the finale
I'm crossing my fingers that she
survives so that she can just show up in
the future and she could still be evil
have tons of fun they definitely said
they're not really gonna address earth
to Laurel on arrow anytime soon
so don't expect any kind of Oliver black
siren crossover maybe next year in like
the big team-up episode that would be
kind of fun but didn't you pick up on
how they did a lot of arrow things they
kind of eulogized Laurel from Earth one
in that moment we didn't just know her
we loved her that that felt like they
were really laying it on thick and then
there's the Wally Felicity take down
with the car just like boom just like
Felicity would do it with the van but
Katie Cassidy was totally fun as black
siren I think she had a lot more fun
playing that character dressing up in
super duper cosplay then playing the
actual Laurel but number three WTF
speaking of which
cosplay on fleek so Cisco and Caitlin
dress up as reverb and killer frost and
it is the most hilarious thing ever like
it starts out pretty intense like
they're just trying to fake her out
stall for time then it goes straight to
scooby-doo territories they're just
running for their lives I totally love
Caitlin Cisco scenes so anytime they're
together there's gonna be a little
scooby-doo in they're my number two WTF
they get rid of the metahumans
everybody's cleaning up Joe jokes about
Barry having kids just you wait I'm
gonna laugh in your face and then
correct Barry's saying my grandkids are
gonna call me pop-pop so I think I said
it during the big earth-2 crossover
episode where Barry sees the picture of
him and iris married on earth to their
children in the comics are called the
tornado twins there's there's no real
hard date on when they were born
but because iris of the comics like the
classic version of iris is secretly from
the distant future
it gets really timey wimey so no idea
how the show is gonna play with that but
for now it's just having fun weaking at
you from behind the camera like no idea
Barry's ever going to like have a vision
of the future and see them that would be
pretty crazy there's also a bit of a
Superman Clark Kent Daily Planet fake
out when the chief is like hey where's
Barry what's he doing and he just zooms
back around oh hey I heard you were
calling for me chief
but like I said number one WTF Henry
Allen killed by zoom I'm gonna make you
feel the same pain we're the same person
we experienced the same childhood
tragedy the same drive to be the fastest
and in the teaser for the next episode
they're teasing a big race let's race to
see who the fastest is clearly it's not
going to be that simple the race is
going to have something to do with what
Cisco vibes earth-2 coming crashing down
just getting destroyed so let me know in
the comments though they're really like
the
question of the day is is do you think
that they're setting it up so that John
Wesley Shipp will be a version of Jay
Garrick on the TV show in the future I
feel like that's where they've been
pushing things because one they said
that Garrick is his mother's maiden name
not Barry's mother but Henry Allen's
mother's maiden name the Morse code that
the man in the iron mask was tapping
they learned was from a war that
happened on earth - a long time ago the
war that zooms dad wore that uniform in
like he said I'm a war hero and he was
wearing that outfit clearly his dad is
not Jay Garrick but maybe Jay Garrick
was part of that war so he wore a
uniform that looked like that too but
let me know what you guys think either
way it seems like they're gonna answer
some of those big questions next week
but you know leaving room to explore
that stuff in season 3 but they've
already started working on season 3 now
I don't think the actors go back to work
to actually start filming episodes till
June or July it might be July but the
writers are already breaking all the big
arcs for season 3 so it's gonna be a lot
of fun to speculate on where all the
characters are headed after next week's
episode but a lot of that will depend on
where they leave all the characters
after the finale like if people end up
dying if people under going back to
earth-2 it all just depends on what ends
up happening the real quick reminder
there is a new round of the giveaway
this week all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card it'll just stay open until I post
my last DC video at the end of the week
I know everybody's freaking out about
Henry Allen but just remember all this
Jay Garrick evidence so don't worry too
much it's okay to be freaked out while
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my Daenerys
unburnt Q&A from last night and you can
click here for my Game of Thrones
episode 4 video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight